long before he started collecting
Infinity stones in the MCU and laid
waste to the Avengers and infinity war
comic readers were well aware that
phallus is undoubtedly one of the
strongest beings in the Marvel Universe
but you know what they say
the bigger they are the harder they fall
and nobody has fallen harder than the
mad Titan how here's a look at seven
Marvel characters who have
single-handedly destroyed Thanos Drax
the destroyer of course Iran was on a
puppet considering he was literally
created to destroy Thanos Drax the
destroyer has a pretty poor track record
getting the feed said time and time
again he had one job but an annihilation
issue for Drax finally managed to take
Thanos out
punching him right through the chest and
literally ripping his heart out of
course he did it at exactly the wrong
time as Santos had just teamed up with
the good guys to save the universe from
the villainous Annihilus that's just so
Drax Adam warlock the full power of the
Infinity gems was on display in 1977
Marvel two-in-one annual issue to where
Thanos attempted to use their might to
destroy the Sun the combined power of
the Avengers and the Allies wasn't
enough to stop him
but luckily they had an Inside Man
literally contained inside the soul gem
was the spirit of Thanos his archenemy
Adam warlock once freed he made short
work of Thanos by turning him into solid
rock hey he said he won at Stone's right
feign early infernos his life the mad
Titan killed his mother his wife his
children and countless millions more in
the hopes of persuading mistress death
to love him and become his wife years
later though during the infinity
crossover event Vitas discovered that
during his travels Pharaoh's fathered an
inhuman eternal hybrid son named Thane
in infinity issue six Thanos finds his
son intent on killing him too however
Thanos is betrayed by his minion ebony
Moore who harnesses stains in a power
over death itself to freeze Sun O's in
an amber like prison known as living
death
zombie Hulk who doesn't like zombies
right Marvel certainly does because
starting in 2005 they began a series of
Marvel Zombies storylines featuring the
Marvel heroes and villains all turned
into brain-eating zombies written by
walking
creator Robert Kirkman himself Marvel
Zombies 2 took place 40 years in the
future after super zombies have eaten
their way across the entire universe
among those left zombie Thanos and
zombie Hulk
and if you think Hulk smashes imagine
how much smashing zombie Hulk does
something that fans learn the hard way
when he made the mistake of getting Hulk
angry hey he did warn us that's my
secret amazing
death the first issue of Thanos is 2016
ongoing solo series ended with the
revelation that Thanos though at the
height of his power to all outward
appearance was dying from a debilitating
illness that left him weak and
eventually powerless so where did this
mystery malady come from in Thanos issue
six fans learned that it was inflicted
by none other than death herself and who
can blame her after having to endure
decades of clearly and wanted advances
from a petulant entitled jerk like vanos
she's not into you bro with his powers
gone Thanos was left vulnerable for a
series of vicious be downs each and
every one of which he totally had coming
[Music]
himself in the classic series Infinity
Gauntlet which inspired the hit film
Avengers infinity war Thanos outdid
himself killing half the universe and
another failed attempt to impress death
and with the power to control all
reality with the Infinity Gauntlet it
seemed as though nothing could stop his
childish anger but it turned out there
was someone who could defeat Thanos
himself yes old pal Adam warlock
revealed to Thanos at first psychic bond
he learned that Pharaoh's secretly knows
he's not worthy of the power he seeks
and verse always unconsciously makes
mistakes allowing himself to be defeated
realizing the truth in warlocks words
Thanos helped warlock regain the
Infinity Gauntlet and restore the
universe Squirrel Girl finally no list
of the Marvel Universe's most powerful
characters would be complete with
Squirrel Girl she has the powers of both
a squirrel and a girl making her and
beatable don't believe us just ask dr.
doom or Galactus both of whom she has
defeated using pluck self-confidence
friendship and of course the help of her
squirrel friends just how awesome is
Squirrel Girl and the GL Xmas special
one-shot Squirrel Girl defeated Panos
with the help of a trusted squirrel
tippy-toe thereby saving the entire
multiverse and in total badass style she
did it off panel because it's such a
given she would win that it's not even
worth the time to show her maybe if he
had used a Thanos copter instead of the
Infinity Gauntlet he would have won
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to